committee stratford-onaven District
Council my name's councilor Lewis Adam
I'm your chairman for this evening
I'll just go through some housekeeping
to begin with if the fire alarm goes off
that's
um
not planned so we need to make an
orderly exit to the wimble pub car park
across the road
where we'll check your names off the
register please make sure your phones
are offer at least in silence so they
don't disturb the flow of the meeting
I'll remind you that this meeting is
being recorded it is a meeting in public
not a public meeting so only those who
are registered to speak are able to do
so at which point they will be called
forward and given further instructions
at that time I'll now introduce the top
table we've got from democratic services
kirikella
we got our solicitor Sue Mullins our
planning manager this evening is Emily
Napier and our planning officers in no
particular order are Malvina hitek
Joseph Brooke and Stuart Flaherty
I believe Emily has a statement she
wants to read out
thank you chair my role tonight is to
provide impartial advice to committee
members and to assist members in their
decision taking thank you
thank you very much uh with that we'll
move on to our first item which is
apologies for absence
I'm counselors
thank you very much uh item two is
disclosure of interest I'm going to
start and say that I was the for item
item six uh I was the ward member for a
previous application
um
um which shared the same site as this on
which I commented uh and spoke at
planning committee as such I don't feel
I can
um chair the committee for that item and
I'll be stepping down and allowing my
vice chair to take over and the other
declaration I have is I was contacted by
the parish council for item number eight
do we have any further Declarations of
Interest councilor Parry
thank you and good evening chair
um as the former Ward member for
wellsborn East
um I will be standing down on the first
application
um Numbers 22 22 forward slash zero
three zero two two wellspawn Hall
thank you very much do we have any
further declarations councilor pampton
uh thank you chair I think we've all had
the same email around application 8 from
the parish council not being able to
attend I believe we just rock that one
yeah and I appreciate that so that can
be a blanket this dispensation any
further items very good in which case we
move to item three which is the minutes
those are the minutes for the meeting
held on the 21st of June 2023 I take it
we've all had an opportunity to read
them
yeah everyone happy no further comments
in which case agreed very good thank you
very much I'll sign those into your
course
very good
um we'll now move on to the agenda uh of
planning applications I'm going to start
by going to item number eight now the
reasons for this being referred to
committee uh are no longer present
um as such I feel it's suitable to
delegate this item to the officers
unless there are any dissenting voices
from committee members
know in which case
um item number eight will be delegated
to officers
we can now then move on to item number
four which covers applications
22-03022 ful and 22 0 3 0 2 3 LBC Wells
born Hall Stratford Road wellsborn
uh presenting officer is Malvina and
when you're ready take it away
thank you chair
um the application site is located in
Wellsburg as denoted by the black dot on
this plan
the site is located within the grounds
of the grade two star list it was born
Hall estate and contains a grade 2
listed Lodge as you can see
okay
just there
um it comprises of two areas served by
separate accesses one which contains the
Brew House to the north accessed via
Church walk
and another which includes the small
world garden and the group of buildings
near the main dwelling
accessed from Stratford Road to the
South
and the site is washed over by the
conservation area designation and is
within the adopted built-up area
boundary of Wellsboro
in terms of the proposals
planning permission and listed building
constant are sold for a conversion of
the garage into a two-bed dwelling
a rebuilt an extension to bothi to
provide one bed dwelling
and creation of private garden areas to
serve the balti and garden Cottage
within the large World Garden there
as well as erection of two number of new
dwellings in the small gold Garden
plot one would provide a four bedroom
dwelling and plot 2 would provide a
three bed dwelling
it is also proposed to rebuild the Brew
House to the north of the side to
provide one bed dwelling
here you can see the brewhouse
um the next slide shows the main
entrance to the estate from Stratford
Road and the proposed reviews area
this plan shows the existing and
proposed ground floor plan
you can see the garage in bothy
here would be the extensions and the
garden serving both the and the garden
serving the lodge
here you can see the proposed elevations
that show the bothi
of the garage
here you can see the existing at the top
of the slide you can see the existing
elevations of the Brew House and at the
bottom you can see the proposed
elevations
here you can see the existing section in
the proposed section and the existing
and proposed floor plan of the Brew
House
so this slide shows the proposed
elevation
of the new dwelling
um also you can see the proposed floor
plans
plot number one would have similar
design
as you can see on this slide
and
this Photograph shows the Brew House
and the Garden Wall
um in the top corner
this photo shows the body
this Photograph shows the garage
this Photograph shows the southern part
of the small world Garden where the
proposed new dwelling would be erected
this photo shows the northern part of
the small world Garden where the second
new dwelling would be erected
this photo shows the neighboring
property to the east of the small Walled
Garden
and this photo shows the West part of
the small world Garden
the recommendation is to refuse the full
and listed building constant
applications for the reasons detailed
within the committee report
thank you
thank you very much we can now move on
to our first Speaker who is counselor
Ann Pryor from wellsborn Parish Council
good evening councilor um you have three
minutes the
turn on the microphone with the button
on the right and I'll turn the red light
on
and once that's on you can start when
you're ready I'll give you a 30 second
warning
thank you chairman councilors
wellsborn Hall is a significant property
in wellesbourne however it's true to say
that the owners of the building over
decades have failed to manage the upkeep
of the property leading to the sad
decline of many of them including the
main house
the current owner is Keen to reverse
this Decline and to date the work that
has been completed on Wisteria Cottage
and the courtyard Cottages which had
been visited by the parish council is a
sympathetic conservation of these
buildings to bring them into use as
Residential Properties
this work has enhanced the area around
the listed building and brought back
into use previously deteriorating
buildings
the parish council has also visited
properties adjacent to the hall to
listen to the residents objections and
review the issues that they have raised
the application for the bothy the brew
house and the garage seat to bring the
same sympathetic restoration
conservation to those buildings to bring
back deteriorating and unsightly
buildings to good order and make them
habitable dwelling houses going forward
the development of the two dwellings in
the small world Garden do not in the
opinion of the parish council create an
uncycling and detrimental impact on the
listed building itself or the buildings
adjacent to the area indeed they enhance
the area by allowing the existing
Heritage buildings to stand out the
properties are modern InDesign and not
thankfully a past station of the other
buildings in the area
the restoration of the Brew House would
not create further traffic down Church
walk as that access is already used by
arrested tenant on this state
the parish council did not think that
the changes to the front of the area
were detrimental to the view of the hall
from Stratford Road it is in fact an
area hidden from View and parking spaces
and sheltered bin storage would not
impact upon this already limited view
the village of wellsborn requires more
rentable properties and this work would
provide properties of a good standard
and the applicant has indicated that
these would be long lets and not holiday
lets
we would ask that the condition be made
that all construction traffic entered
the site from Stratford Road and not
allow the use of church walk for
construction traffic
the parish council supports this
development believing to be a
sympathetic development enhancing the
listed building and not detracting from
it the conservation or other properties
adjacent to it thank you
thank you very much well within your
time members do you have any questions
for our Parish counselor
nothing in which case thank you very
much for your contribution
okay our next speaker is Scott bottles
Mr bottles you've got six minutes
um same procedure so it's the button on
the right I'll give you a 30 second
warning
um and otherwise take it away new and
you're ready
thank you for allowing me to speak my
wife and I own a great star a grade two
star listed house adjacent to wellsborn
Hall
I'm representing the surrounding
neighborhood and objecting to the
proposed application
as I'm sure you've noted there the
application received 40 letters of
objection in total and several of the
neighbor Neighbors who have objected are
here tonight
although only one application is up for
consideration we believe both this
application and the clamping application
should be considered together
regardless the case officer report
provides compelling evidence as to why
this application by itself
should be refused
this evidence includes amongst other
things inadequate amenities flood issues
designs that do not meet building codes
potential noise pollution the removal of
trees and concerns regarding the
conservation of the listed building and
site
we agree with that report and would like
to add our comments regarding the
deleterious effects that the proposed
over development would have on the
surrounding properties
and the Conservation Area
but first I would like to point out that
two of the major reasons cited by the
previous Ward counselor and the parish
council for their support of the
application have been shown to have
limited relevance by the case officer
the previous Ward counselor and the
parish council initially objected to the
application but later reversed their
position the word counselor argued that
the application represented an enabling
development for the refurbishment of
wellsborn Hall
she and the parish council also asked
for a condition that the developed units
would not be let on assured short-term
Tendencies to prevent the site being
used as holiday lets they imply and we
agree that the holiday lets would have a
negative effect on their neighborhood
the case officer notes that there is
insufficient information to justify that
this application qualifies as an
enabling development I spent 35 years in
commercial real estate finance and I can
assure you that the development of new
rental units does not provide the
capital to provide to fund a major
refurbishment of another property
furthermore the case officer states that
the council cannot require that the
units be rented on an assured short-term
tenancies
I would note that the applicant has in
the past rented rooms in wellsborn Hall
on Airbnb therefore there is a risk that
the units could be rented on holiday
lets
I would consequently argue that the two
the two of the main reasons for the
parish council and the counselors
support the application are no longer
relevant
the neighborhood opposes the application
along with a glamping application
because it proposes to turn this the
estate into
an overdeveloped commercial venture the
case officer reported report provides
technical evidence in support of that
argument by way of illustration this
application by its uh by way of
illustration this application by itself
would greatly increase the density on
the site note that the site plan lists
22 parking spaces with another eight
parking spaces in the glamping
application that's 30 spaces in total
although the case officer notes that the
plan is missing a visitor space and the
spaces do not meet size requirements
21 of these spaces 22 if you include the
visitor space are associated with this
application and would access the site
from Stratford Road
the driveway off Stratford Road lies
adjacent to several neighboring
properties the noise and pollution from
this substantial amount of traffic would
detrimentally affect the adjoining
properties and Gardens not to mention
the fact that a portion of the estate
would resemble a car park
The Brew House space and the eight
glamping spaces would access from church
walk
notwithstanding the traffic reports
everyone living in church walk in
Chestnut Square knows that church walk
is a narrow twisting Lane The Cottages
along the lane are historic and most
lack garages for many residents Park
their cars along the lane thereby
reducing the width further this is a
there is no footpath and consequently
pedestrians including children have to
walk in the middle of the lane to access
the public footpath at its end this is a
popular pedestrian route increased
traffic on this Lane would be
detrimental to the safety of pedestrians
and produce noise and pollution to the
detriment of the residents
another example of the over development
concerns the two new bills in the small
Walled Garden this would have a negative
effect not only on the properties
mentioned in the case officer's report
but also on other adjoining properties
as the case officer pointed out there is
inadequate separation between the two
proposed Cottages furthermore a
neighboring property would Overlook the
small Walled Garden creating privacy
concerns for all parties there's also
the potential noise from these new units
which would negatively affect other
adjoining properties
we also have concerns regarding the bin
storage which was set adjacent to a
neighboring property given the proposed
density on the site the bin storage
would be large the odor and noise from
the bins would constitute a nuisance to
the adjoining properties furthermore the
creation of the bin storage would
require the removal of numerous trees
other trees Elsewhere on the estate are
slated for removal the trees along the
boundary of Wells Barn Hall create not
only a privacy screen but provide an
aesthetically important part of the
landscape as well as wildlife habitat in
summary the case officers report by
itself provides compelling evidence to
refuse the application the 40
individuals and groups that posted
objections on the planning site are
concerned that the application by itself
and in conjunction with the glamping
application would overdevelop the site
turning it into a commercial Venture
which would have a deleterious effect on
the estate in the neighborhood
thank you
thank you very much just within your
time members do we have any questions
for our local resident I'll remind you
at this point that we are just looking
at the application in front of us
councilor Keithley
uh thank you very much um thank you Mr
wattles
um I could just like to ask you how have
you with 40 residents making objections
how have you been able to make your
representations to the parish council in
respect of their support of the
application so a few attended Parish
Council meetings to explain your
objections 20 to 25 people have attended
all the parish council meetings
regarding this application the original
application was refused or was
recommended to be refused by the by the
parish council
um I can't speak for the parish council
but numerous people have have shown up
at the parish council to object okay
thank you
any further questions no which case I
think that's everything thank you very
much
our next speakers are Amanda didn't say
Phil Cooksey in Alliston and councilor
Anne Parry
now between you've got three minutes uh
can I ask how you'd like to split your
time
okay
um so yeah I'll give you a 30 second
warning
um before your time is up otherwise uh
take it away thank you thank you members
of the planning committee as the proud
custodian of welsborn Hall since 2018 I
am pleased to present our ambitious
Vision vision for its future which
hinges upon sustainable development and
provision of much needed high quality
rental homes for to meet local demands
our journey commenced with a successful
restoration of the stable block
transform transforming a disuse
structure on the brink of collapse into
two elegant homes whilst retaining
historical charm the restored Cottages
were met with huge demand both
properties let within 24 hours receiving
over 20 inquiries and 10 viewings on the
first day
our aim is to continue revitalizing the
estate and ultimately wellsborn Halls so
that it can once again stand as a symbol
of our cherished Village
we have devoted Over four and a half
years to an in-depth study of the
estate's 330-year history with a
Heritage with our heritage Specialists
over this period we have maintained
constant dialogue with the Stratford
District council's planning and
conservation offices and historic
England and falling four formal
pre-planning applications our design has
been significantly modified in response
to the feedback received
the advantages of a proposal far exceed
any potential harm as validated by the
Heritage report which confirms the
significant public benefits of our
restoration plans
which have not been recognized by the
conservation officer
proposal is acceptable in Heritage terms
and harm has been categorized as on the
lower end of less than substantial
however the planning officers report the
committee hasn't adequately weighed
these merits against the perceived harm
there is no technical basis for the
reasons for refusal as per the technical
evidence provided and the conditions
could be used to address any remaining
concerns we have conducted an exhaustive
flood risk assessment which confirms the
brew house is not within flood zone 2
nullifying any technical grounds for
refusal despite being a Heritage driven
project the officer has has assessed the
proposals using new build guidelines we
have included parking provision discrete
bin storage and thoughtful immunity
space into our plans
the detailed ecological surveys
conducted perceived received no
objection from the Warwick District
house sorry Warwick County Council
ecology our plan ensures net gain and
local biodiversity preservation these
improvements are essential for the
estate's viability and with your
endorsement we can continue the
transformation ensuring sustainability
and Longevity for the future
organizations okay sorry
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our supporters
hmm
Mike please so he was saying was that 30
seconds that was your 30 seconds
so these improvements are essential for
the estate's viability and with your
endorsement we can continue the
transformation
ensuring sustainability and Longevity
for the future generations with while
simultaneously resurrecting the Grandeur
of wellsborn Hall estate to its
deserving preeminence we are grateful
for the support from the parish council
and honorable former Ward member who
appreciate the significance of this
project to the Village thank you for
taking the time to visit the site today
I urge you to waive the benefits and
remember that the harm has been
categorized that's your time now but
yeah thank you thank you
appreciate that okay members do we now
have any
questions for our supporters yes
councilor Harvey
German
um you use the phrase
um significant public benefits yeah
would you like to elaborate please well
Wellsville Hall obviously is a very
important um property in the center of
the old part of wellsborn and we do
appreciate um how how it's you know how
it's sort of presented in the in the
center then is history and and
significance of it so obviously with the
interest
um from the neighbors and The Wider
Community around wellsborn obviously
everybody wants to see the end goal
which is the restoration of the site
ensuring all the Heritage assets are
brought up to and can create longevity
for them so the public benefit is
obviously to maintain this Heritage item
which is you know as you've been seeing
from the site visit today
The Brew House the garage the the the
the bothy they're all on the verge of
dilapidation or collapse so the public
benefit is so that we can actually open
up the site actually the village can
also
um experience what we we want to bring
back into to its life and also obviously
you know the other public benefit
obviously is the demand for local rental
properties as well so you know we've
already demonstrated you know the level
of demand that there is there and and
I'm constantly getting calls for for
availability of properties in the area
so we know this a shortage thank you any
further questions
thank you chair
um thank you in your presentation you
mentioned that you'd had significant
contact with the planners and the
conservation officer one of the areas
that I noted on my visit was that the
two new builds are quite close together
and and Overlook each other both with a
lot of glass
what I'm interested to know is what
account you took of the comments that
you would have got from the council and
the conservation officer in in in
proposing two new builds in such close
proximity
well I mean so we've obviously looked at
you know the Aesthetics of the garden
space we want to make sure that we
create as much or rather leave as much
Garden space as we can we you know we've
Incorporated ensuring that there's
privacy and for you know the amenity
space for both both dwellings but also
based on the feedback from the
conservation officer we didn't want to
have long like lamb high level Hedges
either so you know the discrete
um this discrete privacy there and we
will have amenity space obviously as
well
um but also they have access to the
broader immunity around around the
estate as well
I'm not sure if I've answered your
question for you there um well yes it
does thank you you say that you've
considered it and they would have
privacy correct thank you
councilor passing him
um
um I noticed that a number of mature
trees
um I plan you you uh you want to cut
down
is there any way that you could um do
the same development without so much
damage too so I think two mature trees
that we're looking to remove are the
four
um what are the few trees I think behind
the the garage and that's just to create
a little bit of um additional space
behind the garage which would be
converted into dwelling
um but in in our broader landscape
strategy we're we're looking to plant
many trees especially bringing the
paddocks and trying to reinstate that
back into a woodland so any trees will
be replanting way more than we would be
taking I think it's only those four or
five trees if I remember correctly that
we're taking down in that space I think
there's one large Conifer actually in
the South Wall Garden which is in the
footprint of one of the dwellings on the
on the south side of the wall
but again like I said in our broader
landscape strategy we'll be planting
significant significant amounts of
numbers of trees
can I just add um there has been a
program of tree management works on the
site since Harminder bought the site and
as he mentioned the wider Park land
which Falls within the blue line of the
application
um does have a proposal for quite
extensive management and planting going
forward
obviously that's a program of works
that's going to take place over a period
of time there have been some tree works
in the last couple of years so for
example to protect the drainage system
on the site
and some of the damage to the buildings
on the site has also been caused by the
trees not just from Roots but also from
branches over sailing
um so Sun there's been some tree
trimming Works related to that
any further questions from members
no in which case thank you very much all
for your contributions thank you for
your time
okay our final speaker on this item is
counselor Ostrander who is substituting
Phil councilor Johnson
good evening councilor
so you've got five minutes I'll give you
a 30 second warning it's the button on
the right
and um when you're ready take it away
thank you chair in a moment I would like
to refer to the site plan in appendix
one for this item on page 35 as a
reports pack so can I just check if it's
possible to display that please
okay super thank you at the outset could
I say that I would not ask a committee
to do anything other than accept the
recommendation of refuse contained in
the report
a point about myself I've been involved
in public life in wellsborn since
joining the parish council in 2004. I
became well aware of the traffic issues
in church walk when I led the
discussions with the BBC restoration
fund and the Heritage Lottery fund on
the renovation of Chatham's yard after
we had won the popular vote and the
restoration Village program
Chatham's yard is close by in the other
arm of church walk to the east of this
site
a couple of points of context welsborn
is at significant flood risk if the
flood defenses on the river Dean are
breached it is properties in these areas
of the Old Village in church walk
Chestnut Square Bridge Street and Chapel
Street which are most affected
Church walk was designed before the
motor vehicle it is narrowest at its
Southern exit to join Chestnut Square
when Chatham's yard was given planning
permission in 2009 a condition was
imposed to require visitors to park
elsewhere and walk to the yard
I believe the plan of the site on page
35 is misleading
the land included in the box to the
north of the site and the hook on the
right hand side
just give you a moment to locate that
is land which is not owned by anyone it
was recently resurfaced by the owners of
number 13 and number 36.
I visited the site two weeks ago and was
pleased to hear of the Ambitions of the
owner of the site including the
renovation of the hall itself I do note
the comments of counselor Pryor and of
the parish council whose views I always
value
a different application might not
generate the same concerns however the
impact on the rest of the site the
access from church walk and the
contradictions of planning policy forced
me to conclude that this application
should be refused
thank you
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our substitute Ward member
no not in which case thank you very much
right we now move on to points of
clarification from our officers members
are there any points of clarification
councilor Harvey
thank you chairman
um
Mr didn't say made an assertion that
the uh the brewery
was not in flood zone two
the officer's report states that it is
in flood zone two is it invloit zone two
yes according to the data on the
government website that shows flood
zones
I have a slide that shows the extent of
the flood zone if you wish to see
perhaps
um
is that everything for that question
Council happy
I presume the dark area in the top left
hand Corners flood zone three
uh yes correct and the light blue zone
is flood zone too
thank you very much I do have a question
as well actually
um there was a point made by The
Substitute War member regarding
ownership of the land
um in that segment
um do you have any elaboration on how
material that is in uh in regards to
this application
yes so
um
and it has come to light that part of
the application Site Area is
unregistered and however
um the applicants submitted correct
certificate of ownership and they served
notice in accordance with the procedure
so the process has been followed through
and
we consider that the application can be
determined on on that basis
thank you very much any further Council
Pemberton
thank you chairman the applicant
suggested that the space standards being
applied were those for
new build
can officers clarify whether there are
differing standards for new build versus
conversions particularly as these are
sort of old building conversions or I'll
do the standards apply regardless
if I if you mean the garden amenity or
like space standards in the building or
the separation distances is it like so
everything I I picked up from the
applicant's comments that the internal
space standards that you have
highlighted are inadequate in at least
one of the buildings our standards that
apply to new build as opposed to
conversion of buildings so I'm just
trying to clarify are there a
differential set of Standards depending
on whether this is a ground up brand new
build or whether it's a conversion of an
older building just seeking some clarity
on uh where whether we're we're apples
and apples so to speak
technically
um the there isn't uh we haven't got a
policy that specifically says
um
this dwelling shall be this minimum size
so what officers have to do is they have
to make a judgment
um and when they make a judgment they
will use
um information that's available to them
so obviously there are nationally set
space standards so when an officer is
making their assessment if they feel
that
um the the level of immunity afforded to
a dwelling
um is something to be concerned of as
part of their their judgment they may
sense check that against the ndss which
has been referred to within the officer
report but obviously you know
it could apply equally to to new
dwellings as much as conversions and
they will they will be considering it
generally as to the level of immunity
that's afforded for that dwelling so
just to clarify there aren't two
different sets of space standards
depending on whether it's a brand new
build or a conversion
thank you
any further upon School applications if
you don't mind Jay yeah it's just
picking up on councilor pemberton's
Point these standards that you refer to
which seem to appear quite a lot in the
report about amenity of garden space or
the size of properties these standards
are they hard and fast numbers or are
they guidance
um
so
[Music]
um
for example the minimum standards for
for residential Garden
um they are guidelines contained in a
part of the development requirements SPD
so it is up to the committee members to
decide how much weight they afford to to
the guidelines
um so in the officer's report obviously
I've taken them into account together
with some national standards to make a
planning judgment whether
us as a case officer I consider that the
proposed amenity
um that would be serving the future
occupiers of these dwellings is
sufficient
thank you
I think on that point sorry just to come
in the the my reference to to the
standards that we don't have is the
internal space standards but obviously
the officers also referred to to our
separation distance standards that are
set out in our rspd sorry just to make a
point of clarification
any further points of clarification
hello
in which case we can move on to the
debate who would like to start us off
don't all jump at once councilor Harvey
thank you chairman
um the Merit in this application is I
appreciated is the provision of new
housing in an area which requires new
housing
that said
um I think there are some important
factors that militate against approval I
start by pointing out that this is a
great welderborn hall and its cartilage
is agreed to Star listed building in
other words it is of particular
importance and it's sort of more than
special interest
there are only 5.8 percent of listed
buildings on grade 2 Star so it is a
very significant building
secondly we have the building lie apart
from being listed it lies in a
conservation area and we have a piece of
legislation planning act 1990 which as
far as uh list of building is concerned
requires us to have special regard
to the application to the merits of the
application and as far as a conservation
there being in a conservation area we
have us we have an obligation to to
apply special attention to the
application
furthermore paragraph 197 of the nppf
requires us to attach great weight to be
given to the assets conservation
the officer has produced a report which
highlights the views of the conservation
officer conservation officers view is
fairly clear very clear
added to which the case officer has
reported various other shortcomings that
she identifies them so for instance the
lack of any immunity space for the for
the Brew House
the inadequacy of the size of the
parking spaces that are proposed the
inadequate space between buildings that
are proposed so without getting into
questions of whether
the design is it has appeal or not I
think there are
significant hurdles and significant
responsibilities on members of the
committee to have regard to which leads
me to conclude that I support the case
officers decision or sorry
recommendation to refuse and I'm happy
to propose
thank you very much because the
Pemberton next
thank you I find myself in agreement
with councilor Harvey and I'm prepared
to Second uh his proposal to to back
office his recommendations in doing so I
would just like to make two comments
um I do think that the applicant has
worked hard to try and make this fly
I just don't think they're quite there
yet
I think that with some uh the immunity
the amenity elements do concern me I I
understand what they're trying to do and
I've got a lot of sympathy with it but I
think they're just not quite there yet
the other
on well an aside observation is that
there's there is also an another
application for this site and it is
clear that there is a
at least well there's certainly a public
feeling and I think from a planning
perspective it just doesn't hang right
that we're not seeing the full picture
and I think I would be urging officers
to
engineer that when this inevitably does
come back before this committee if this
committee is minded to refuse that we
that we try to sequence this so we're
looking at the entire picture almost on
a master plan basis as councilor Harvey
says grade two stylistic building I'm
uncomfortable with uh developments being
parceled up and separated when
inevitably they are inter interlinked in
the real world and I I use the analogy
of the Birmingham Road where plot after
plot after plot was brought forward
separately and we are unable then to
consider the bigger picture I would urge
officers to
find a way that when this site does come
back that we're in a position to
consider everything in the round but I
am happy to back cancel the Harvey in uh
backing offices
recommendations here thank you chair
thank you very much
yeah thank you chairman
um I do have some empathy with the the
applicant they've got a number of of
dilapidated buildings that they really
need to try and do something with and in
my view it's about what viable
Alternatives there might be to these
buildings like the Brew House and the
bothy that I saw today so I can see why
um this proposal to look after these
buildings and bring them back into use
is a good thing
um otherwise I just think they'll just
end up falling down and I don't think
we'd want that but I have some real
concerns about the over development what
I see is the over development of these
small Walled Garden with two properties
that are quite substantial
um overlooking each other with a lot of
glass I'm concerned about that and the
privacy and I'm concerned about the
um
the the sort of yeah I'd call it General
over development of the site
um where if I was considering perhaps
bringing back into use the existing
buildings I think I I would probably be
more sensitive to it but I'm
looking at what the conservation
officers saying and thinking about how
we need to give a special regard to the
preservation of that Hall and its set it
as a grade two star so I'm
in in agreement with the councilors
Harvey and councilor Pemberton in in
respect of going with the office's
recommendation
thank you very much any further speakers
on this councilor pattingham
yeah the existing buildings did look
very dilapidated and it's important that
they are brought back into use in some
way otherwise we're going to lose a
great two listed star build build
buildings and um and that's important
but it it's unfortunate that um it does
seem like
uh over development especially the the I
agree that two new buildings in the wall
Garden
um but yeah I think it's important that
that something comes forward perhaps in
the future if we refuse it that that it
is maintained properly and and uh
and the the whole
um site is is conserved
thanks very much um Council Fleming next
yeah
who's not on
on the building side at the moment so
um you know we often hear the saying if
it's not quite right it's not right and
this isn't quite right
um so I think that there are there must
be and we're not here to debate other
schemes what's in front of us what's in
front of us isn't right and I think with
a little bit of work and a little bit of
application I'm sure they can come up
with something that will fit the job and
save the buildings which is just
important thank you
thanks very much I think I'd agree with
the massive majority of what's been said
uh would anyone like to speak on this
item before we go to a vote about a
proposal and a seconder for refusing in
line with the officer's recommendations
can I see all those in favor
that's unanimous
um this then in which case we also have
to have
a proposal and a seconder for the second
part of this application which is the
LBC
proposed by councilor Pemberton
foreign
all those in favor
in which case committee resolves to
refuse applications
22-03022 ful and 22
03023 LBC
okay we can now move on to our next item
which is
item number five application
2300739 ful five Hilliard Road southam
uh presenting officer is Stuart Flaherty
and when you're ready let's do it take
it away
thank you chairman good evening
this proposal is seeking planning
permission for the direction of a new
dwelling and Associated development on
existing residential land this proposal
seeks the subdivision of an existing
plot here we see the location of the
site with the black dot uh denoting the
location here
um here we see satellite imagery of the
application site the site resides within
the adopted Build-A-Bear boundary of
sell them uh one can see that it here
one can see that it is on a corner plot
in the heart of a housing estate
uh here we have an existing layout plan
of the site the blue line to the
immediate north of the application site
uh denotes land ownership the
application site is predominantly Garden
land as currently uh
its existing form uh there is to be a
shed and Greenhouse removed as part of
this development
uh here we see the proposed site layout
plan uh the proposed dwelling is to be
this to the south of number five
Hillyard Road and to the west of number
one Hilltop close uh one can also see on
this plan amongst other matters uh where
the proposed vehicle access is to be
um achieved off Hilltop close here
uh here we have the proposed elevations
of the dwelling
um one can see that the material palette
proposed is to com is to comprise of
facing brickwork and render
uh in addition here to the the top of
this screen here you can see an
indicative visual of how this proposed
dwelling would sit in the street scene
when viewed from Hillyard Road
um so just to elaborate on that the
whereby cursor is there is the host
dwelling number five here to the far
right is the proposed dwelling the
subject of this application this evening
uh we now have a photo or two of the
site here we are stood near the corner
of the two roads looking at the host
dwelling here
um
the proposed dwelling is to be cited uh
in here where my cursor is currently
hovering over
um we now have a slightly uh slightly
different Vantage Point looking at the
wider context of the area
um one can see the prominent corner here
of between the two roads where this
dwelling is to be proposed
[Music]
um
officers consider that this proposal
unfortunately does not comply with the
development plan and supplementary
planning guidance this proposal is
considered to not contribute possibly to
the what street scene and is found to
have a harmful impact on the wider
character and in particular this
prominent Corner plot I refer you all to
the update sheet for further details uh
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
this application for the reason sis out
on pages 42 and 43 of your agenda thank
you
thank you very much sure our first
speaker on this item is Roland Lloyd
Thomas agent for the application
good evening it's the button on the
right to turn on the microphone you have
three minutes so I can give you a 30
second one
yep two seconds
thank you good evening chairman
councilors my name is Roland Lloyd
Thomas of Lloyd Thomas Architects acting
and designer and agent for this
application
we were approached by the applicant to
redesign the scheme and address the
three reasons for the previous refusal
of the proposal for a new dwelling
highways had concerns about the previous
scheme and the original vehicular access
proposed off Iliad road we have
therefore redesigned the layout of the
scheme completely and now proposed
vehicular access of the cul-de-sac
Hilltop close
WCC highways have confirmed that this
fully satisfies their concerns and they
have removed their rejection this has
been acknowledged by the case officer
a full landscape report from an
arboriculturalist has now been provided
and it concludes that there are no
features of Interest either within or
adjacent to the site the site plans show
that where the existing Hedges can be
added to and increasing the biodiversity
and habitat on the site this again has
been acknowledged by the case officer in
the report which confirms the scheme now
complies with policy CS5 landscape
the officer has also stated that the
there is a 2.1 meter high fence that
would be placed to these side and rear
boundaries this is incorrect and not
mentioned anywhere in the proposal
there is an existing boundary hedge to
the rear of the pavement of Hilltop
close and the applicant would be willing
to accept a height restriction on that
hedging to Hillyard Road
on the curb of the junction which would
ensure the situation regarding openness
is not changed at all in fact it would
be improved as part of the current
boundary fencing would be removed to
allow for the parking as proposed
the design is very similar to the
existing properties as you can see from
the street scene image
it takes reference from its neighbors in
terms of the pitch roof the materials
the bricks the tile Groove the door and
window design the only difference is how
it turns the corner and addresses
Hilltop close we have the next two
images please
the case officers also stated in his
report that the house almost immediately
abuts the southern pavement Edge this is
incorrect the design of the building has
been carefully broken down to reduce the
math Mass on its Southern face so it's
only single story or open canopies that
face Hilltop close the full two-story
element is 3.1 meters back from the
pavement Edge there are other properties
on the estate that are nearer to the
pavement than this and the positioning
of the property in its design retain the
openness of the corner and the general
design principles of this eclectic
estate
the glazing to the side of the existing
property can easily be relocated to the
rear elevation looking towards their
remaining Garden this plot is easily big
enough for two properties and the scheme
provides adequate parking and amenity
space both points made by the officer
it's a wholly sustainable site on bus
routes close to essential amenities of
the town and whilst this plot won't
solve the housing crisis it provides one
more much needed dwelling with a design
that is in keeping without affecting
highway safety or the amenity of its
neighbors thank you
thank you very much just within your
time members do you have any questions
for the agent so suffocation
counselor Eden
thank you chair
um just back to your visuals that that
were the last two that were up and it
shows a very open
corner is that exactly as it would be
with nothing around it
but the uh the open corner will be
retained in the same as it is now with a
low hedge and my contention is that the
site will be actually more open because
there's more of the six foot fencing
that currently exists would be removed
certainly more of the uh existing six
foot fencing that currently exists along
that boundary and is continuous along
that boundary will be removed
any further questions
okay in which case thank you very much
for your contribution
right so
um councilor Bromwich is the ward member
he registered to speak for the
um for the last committee when this item
came forward unfortunately isn't
available to be here tonight but um I
agreed to read the statement that he uh
he prepared
um on uh for full committee so I'll just
run through that now
before giving my comments I wish to
declare I've spoken to the applicant
who's known to me his architect and
residents many of whom are known to me
in all cases I have given advice and
guidance based on planning law and
policy I also advise residents on how to
make comments and give representations
in line with planning law and policy
their comments and concerns were given
to councilor Crump who submitted them to
the council
I also gave information to the applicant
on the present presentation process at
the planning committee in all cases I
have tried to remain impartial and
objective to all parties concerned
I note with interest the planning
officers report and make the following
observations one in context with the
other dwellings with Hilltop close the
designs within the context of the rest
of the road given over the years many of
the dwellings have
various alterations to the frontages I
would not consider this out of place to
inciting of the property appears to be
in line with the existing properties so
I do not consider this to be a concern
three I know the planning officer
stating the following I can only return
to the observation that the corner plots
on
and in the vicinity of Hilliard Road are
characterized by their spaciousness and
Greenery these characteristics
contribute positively to the street
scene and to the character and
distinctiveness of this state the
contribution that is particularly
valuable in the case of this estate
building
on one of the those Corner plots would
erode those characteristics thereby
contributing negatively to the street
scene and to the local character and
distinctiveness
this appears to be very strange comment
in regards to Hilliard Road to the south
of the road there is no Greenery and the
turning into Glebe Road whilst one side
of the Turning is lawned the opposite
side is not to the north the only
Greenery is on Welsh Road West and the
turning into Hilltop close has no
Greenery I find the quote included in
the planning officers report to not be a
true representation of the area in
general for I have taken on board
residence concerns these I think can be
addressed by the planning committee
the first issue raised is a concern of
visibility of a junction turning onto
Hilltop close the committee could place
a height restriction on any hedge the
existing hedge does
good does allow good visibility
the next concern raised to me was in
regards to parking on the road firstly I
would point out that the law states that
you cannot park within 10 meters of a
junction so those concerns should be
addressed in regard to the law and not
planning applications five residents
have raised concerns that the applicant
currently has Works Vehicles parked
within the vicinity of his property this
as I explained to them cannot be
considered by the planning committee the
other parking issue raised was accessing
the driveway due to the height of the
existing fence
I believe this could be resolved with a
mirror being fitted and maybe someone
could agree to this
six the street scene line I do not
consider that this is an issue as the
current properties are staggered along
Hilltop close and I do not think it will
have a significant impact on the street
scene other than improve the current
wooden fence which I think looks more
out of place than the applicants
proposal
submission to the committee uh obviously
I'm not the world member so I can't take
questions in which case we move on to
points of clarification for the officer
members do we have any uh points
clarification
no counselor Keithley
sorry I was just a bit slow thinking
there
um yes thank you chairman
um we've just heard from the Ward
members statement
um that uh he he sort of disagrees with
the representation of the open space of
the corners in in that vicinity on that
state and he's he's challenging
um the the assessment of the streetscape
have you got anything you can show us so
we can see the other Corners perhaps so
that we can get a a feel for how open
those Corners are we've only actually
seen a photograph of the the plot in
question I think
thank you uh thank you councilor I can
certainly give it a try
um I've got a visual here although I can
see our screens have just gone down I
don't know
if that's it that might prohibit matters
if I can
feel great
thank you so much
um thank you again for the question
counselor I can give you a snapshot as
best I can what I should also say is as
reflecting the update she is I believe
some members attended a member site
visit
um and I've seen this site in the flesh
I believe
um the other thing to say uh I do have a
snapshot of some photos which perhaps
I'll go through slowly now these are a
no obvious order but they are intended
to give a snapshot of the surroundings
um if I perhaps just go through them
slowly
um this is the fencing question where
whether the dwelling is supposed to be
for example
um
again looked at from a slightly
different angle
um
perhaps I might just let the slides
actually do a bit for talking perhaps
um if you are asking for a snapshot of
the surroundings
let's go
I mean I don't know how much that will
assist you counselor but that's
something of a Whistle Stop tour but
there is
um some visual aids there to help to
give a better appreciation of the area
yeah thanks for that okay any further
points of clarification councilor Eden
uh thank you
do you have
almost uh one of the plan reviews
of the proposed site from above on the
corner I'll just have another look at
please
that with that one
that's the proposed site layout plan
that's something yeah that's perfect
okay any further points of clarification
Pemberton
is through you chair
um could I just could you just re-scroll
through there was an image and I'll tell
you when to stop uh I just wanted
just to another it was a different view
of the street scene
if you go through slowly I'll tell you
when to stop it was yeah from the ones
that you just flicked through very
quickly for
sure
that's it so that's the current building
and that's the six foot fence that's the
application side is that correct
or is this a difference is that a
different corner there
um I believe I didn't take this photo
here's into our Council as well I'll try
and assist as best I can um I believe
this photo is taken from the board of
the application site looking back
yourself as I see it but again I wasn't
there I'm afraid can you just scroll
through the next one please for me
not having had the uh
benefit of being on the site visit
I've seen enough thank you any further
points of clarification I think we've
definitely seen the photos fairly
thoroughly anyone no in which case we
can move to the debate anyone care to
jump in of the Parry
thank you chair
um at least I had the benefit of
actually going going to the site
um a couple of weeks ago
um
and
extensively obviously read the report
yes the site is in a very sustainable
location the issues I have with this
particular application is the size and
the bulk of what is proposed and as you
go down the
um further down into here we are close
the other properties are quite set back
so I can understand the officers
concerns about the building line
um I fully appreciate why the applicant
believes and and wants to put another
dwelling on the site
I just my my having looked at it I just
feel it's a little bit in terms of scale
and size and also an element of design a
little bit
too big and
um would have preferred to have seen
something a bit smaller come forward so
I am inclined to go along with the
officer's recommendation
very much that proposal
yep counselor Adam next
thank you chair um
I agree with the officer in as much as
it is ambitious I do think it is and
I'll be honest I quite like the design I
think it's really clever how they try to
address the issues there my problem is
exactly that view there where it shows
that the building lines it's not in line
it's not in line with anything and its
design itself versus the rest of the
street scene is as the officer also
pointed out incongruous so for me I'm uh
it doesn't quite work as clever as it is
um so I'm going to Second councilor
Parry
very much councilor Hench Serafin next
okay
um I quite inclined to agree with cancer
Barry and Neil Eden they've taken my uh
voice out of it so I'll agree with the
officer's recommended
thank you councilor Pemberton next I
believe
thank you I'm in agreement um sometimes
you can be too clever for your own good
um there are some places that you yet
there's enough room to to build but you
just don't have to you just it's just
not right this is the design of these
Estates do lead to large Corner plots
that it's a vernacular all over the
country and just because you can
shoehorn something it doesn't mean to
say that it's appropriate in planning
terms to do so and I would I I really
struggle with this it is contrived I
yeah I I applaud the ambition but it's
contrived it doesn't work and I think
that the the officers nailed it in terms
of just one simple reason for refusal
thank you very much councilor pattingham
well
um I am
I can't see how it is detrimental to the
street scene and
um the argument about it being contrived
is very subjective
uh I think everybody's going to have
different opinions on how they should
design houses so I can't see any great
objection to it so I'd be in favor of
the um you know the of the development
Council Harvey I like councilor Perry I
had the advantage of having actually
been to the site and not only been to
the site but driven around the area
there are I recognize you didn't take
the photographs and you weren't you're
not the present you are presenting us
but not the case officer there are other
photographs you could have taken which
showed corner corner plots which are
very open
um there's one further down that
particular Road
um had this been an application a
proposal for a one-story extension side
extension to the house we wouldn't we
wouldn't be here it would have been
dealt with my office I suspect but I
um I can't get away from
the the words in the report
um that it would appear awkward and
contrived and
uh I've listened to
the the speaker and he's designed
something specifically for the site and
it is clever but I still don't I can't
get away from the fact that I still
agree that it's awkward in its setting
and it's and its appearance would be
somewhat contrived so I'm happy to
support a vote for refusal
thank you very much any further speakers
on this I mean I think um I mean I was
at the site visit and one of the things
that did occur to me which I think
doesn't get reflected particularly well
by the elevations we see is the way in
which it does step back because the
neighboring properties have single story
areas out front before the full Gable so
I think particularly for me that
indicated that the uh the setting of
this would be um much more dominating of
the street scene than couldn't be seen
just from this I certainly found the
site was it used on that uh in that
regard
um on that basis we got a proposal on a
second or for refusing in line with the
officer's recommendations can I see all
those in favor
that's eight well there's post one
in which case committee resolves to
refuse application 23
00739 ful
thank you very much
all right we're now moving on to item
six
um which as I previously stated I have a
declaration of interest in so I'll be
handing over to my vice chair councilor
Keithley
well thank you very much chairman
um so moving on to
agenda item six this is application
2301305 which is land near to Middle
Road Farm Middle Road harbory it's a
solar panel site and our case officer is
Joe Brooks Joe if I could pass across to
you please thank you chair
there we go let me just get that working
properly
the application before you is for
fundamentally for a solar farm which
I'll go into more detail during the
presentation
ultimately it is crossed two parishes so
as indicated by the red line boundary
this is the parish often as you can see
by the cursor there and then the second
part of the site to the South is within
the Parish of harboring Harbor is just
Associated there
the Foss way runs along so there is part
of the fast way within the application
site to connect the two together
and it is fundamentally for 49.99
megawatts it is proposed to utilize 14
500 homes annually
and it is a for a period of 40 years and
six months
the application site as a whole
encompasses 89 hectares the application
would entail the installation the number
of solo PV panels Associated works and
Landscaping all this is set without in
the port in the report
the various development on site will see
its primary was still Frameworks to
support the panels and we utilize a
bifacial panels so basically and I can
show this in a minute with the
certifying where the sun is moving
around the solar panel itself will
follow the where the sunlight is is
Ultimate use
in addition there will be inverters
Transformer and a battery container I
will introduce plus deer fencing and CCT
security system predominantly made of
infrared cameras for security reasons
[Music]
so this gives you more of a context of
the application site on Google Earth
what I would say in highlight 2 members
is this is a resubmission of an
application submitted last year the
reason I would say that then the East
stating report has been a number of
alterations and elements but the biggest
one being is previously this grade out
area here has been now removed and there
is more detailed plans in a minute to
show that so fundamentally and this is
indicative after I like so I've done
this this is where the solar panels will
be situated from the village of roughton
and this is fundamentally whether we're
situated from harboring fossway
obviously goes down there and that's the
side from roadly into a from there and
that leads onto our facility and so
forth to the north
this is the plan showing the often soil
development more close in detail as you
can see feels five and six are now
proposed with no solar panels filled
seven still is solar panels and the
village of often is situated down there
so this whole area which encompasses The
Farmstead here will be applicative solar
panels if they're permitted
this is in the harboring side of the
application what I should also highlight
is this Farmstead here liso Farm is gray
two listed this is set out in the report
some mitigation buffer has been proposed
there most of the inverted substations
and connectivity will be associated in
fields 8 and 12.
as you can see by that element there
side panels the solar panels are to be
arranged on Metal Frames pushed into the
ground they are to be finished in a
non-reflective dark color to maximize
absorption and will extend 3.1 meters in
height at the highest point and 1.1
meters at the lowest point so as you can
see the angles on the 60 degree angle so
that makes it higher and lowest points
your eyes will be mounted on single
access tracker mounting structure which
will be constructed from a simple metal
framework mounted on poles that will be
driven to and grown thus avoiding the
need for substantive foundations the
panels will be laid in north south rows
with spacing in between which could
allow for seat grazing and to avoid
shading
so we come into the photos as you can
see the red arrow is slightly small
unfortunately but the Red Arrow show is
roughly where I took this photo that's
looking to serve for the fields
predominantly they're further north of
this field roughly there will be solar
panels and following the same suit going
across this road here is the sorry from
Road region up into often
this is taken from the same varnish
point just off the red line boundary but
as you can see it details the often
houses and the road leading into often
the white Harper is located within this
vicinity
and come across
this after the photo is taken from the
lvia but I've included it gives you good
perspective and I have checked all the
wordings it is accurate in that it gives
you the side from road coming up this is
the area of the solar panels that's
going to be situated coming across here
this also gives you the area of Harvey
where it's going to be situated Crown
Hills in the distance and Western fields
are there and there you have Radford
simulator Farm just located within the
vicinity
so this is Radford similarly solar farm
as you can see right the plan there is
situated fundamentally in the middle of
the two major solar farm sites from the
two parishes and gives you an indication
of solar rays within the vicinity
this is taking up Middle Road so this is
just heading into harbury as you
indicated by the radar Ro you've got
Middle Road Farm here and you've got the
south portion there and Littlefield
Littlefield house the solar air panels
would be situated within this vicinity
Behind These so if you look at the key
to the right that's the area that solar
panels will be situated behind the
dwellings and to the field on the other
side which is this field
so you can see all that area would be
allocated if the solar rays include in
this area up to the north
this is then taken from the field
looking across from the access point so
as these indications here where the
solar rays would be you've got the West
Hills Cottage the boundaries exist in
boundaries and uh looking straight
across the Solar Ray panels
and that's it for presentation chair
office of recommendation is for approval
I set out and Report with 33 recommended
conditions and also there has been some
updates which I would advise members to
review on the update sheet thank you
thank you very much Joe
um right we have some speakers
um first of all I'd like to invite
councilor John Taylor
and Jackie Chapman so John's the
chairman of Upton Parish Council
and Jackie's the clerk of Upton Parish
Council
to the table if you'd like when you
speak if you could press the right hand
button you'll get a little
community-owned
should that mean that I should step down
um I don't know Sue
um
ultimately it's a matter for you but you
have to consider whether or not your
mind is sufficiently open or whether you
could be perceived to have some bias
towards solar farm
S as a result
oh okay right I better step I better
step away okay thank you councilor
passing and we've decided to step down
from this committee I would consider
this yeah thank you we'll note your um
Declaration of Interest
yes okay thank you so you've got three
minutes
between you to understand that you'll be
speaking and Jackie you're here in case
any questions is that right okay so I've
got a clock I'll I'll give you a 30
second warning
the right side button
um John the right side one okay so when
you're ready
uh good evening everybody uh I'm here to
speak to oppose this application
we have four major points to address
here I'm going to address items one and
two and Susan Ostrander will address
three and four
thly
this application was rejected in October
last year
the wording used in the committee report
was I quote
the proposal has a significant
urbanizing effect on the landscape
character and so it is not considered
that the development could be made
acceptable or that the benefits outweigh
the harm
this has not changed significantly with
the resubmission
this proposal is very clearly contrary
to policies CS5 and cs9 of the Stratford
core strategy 2011-2031
also
planning guidance is that cumulative
effect must be considered
within a six mile radius of often
there are so far five existing solar
Farms five approved two under
consideration we have Fuller details of
these to hand if you wish to to look at
them
we conclude that sdc's local strategy
and urbanizing and cumulative effects
must lead us to reject this application
second Point landscape
are first slide please
uh yes thank you it's very similar to
when we saw saw earlier actually
this was taken about 700 meters from
often at the boundaries of the proposed
site
and I put it there to illustrate that
whilst the Foss way is about 60 meters
above sea level often Rises quite
sharply up to the point you could see on
the horizon there at about 110 meters
the applicant states that quote the
visual influence of the scheme would be
highly localized and limited given the
topography and tree cover we we cannot
agree with this
you are
almost certainly aware of a solar farm
existing between halvory and Bishop City
in itchington it's unseen
and that's because it's on high ground
and that's a great example of a solar
farm in the right place
there's 30 seconds left John thank you
slide two please
this is Harry's rise an ancient Road
from the village to lemington a place
that accept accessible to all
and slide three please from the garden
of the white heart
this is our local pub
in some of very many customers enjoy the
salinity the last one in our village
Mr chairman
Topography is very important here
none of the no amount of the Landscaping
will work the Vista is not localized and
not limited as the applicant insists it
would urbanize and dominate as
previously has been recognized thank you
thank you very much
okay
um members do we have any questions for
the presenters please
yes counselor hence everything thank you
um this land has proposed for the solar
farm yes it's agricultural land isn't it
yes I need to be farmed all the time yes
and if I if I may uh that's point the
next point that we're going to discuss
which Susan Ostrander will talk about
and I hope that will that will answer
your question better than I will okay
thank you
any further questions
okay thank you very much
okay next we've got
um
representations from the applicant so if
I could invite Harry Wilder and Keith
McKinney
and Rachel Gaffney forward please to the
table thank you
so you have
three minutes can I ask if you've
considered how you might split three
minutes between you
oh
I sent an email saying we couldn't
accept photo montages in a certain
according to our procedures
nothing else was when I sent the email I
just said sort of noted I'm going to
show different sizes of photos of it I
can't show those
okay so um you have three minutes and
I'll give you
a 30 second countdown to that thank you
thank you very much so my name is Harry
Wilder and I'm here to speak on behalf
the applicant to ask this committee
tonight to follow the recommendation
that we've had from the two senior
planning officers who've reviewed both
applications to approve this application
this is a resubmission of application
22-0001 ful which was recommended again
for approval but at November we did lose
by one vote
the previous application which was
prepared in 2021 was prepared during the
covert pandemic and we were unable to do
physical events for the public
consultation we heard during the
previous planning committee that when
that went to determination 2022 we were
told that it would be much better if
we'd be able to go and speak with the
low Community we listened and for this
application we did two Community
consultation events alongside a
um the virtual consultation we did
previously
we have subsequently amended the layout
that we're showing here today to address
some of the primary concerns that we had
from people who came I would also note
that the majority of people who came are
in sport of solar energy
the Amendments we've made are to remove
the fields five and six and the reason
we did that was that for the views from
the village of afternoon predominantly
the pub and the Community Asset that
represents by removing Fields five and
six and adding in a 10 meter buffer
which that photograph is taken looking
back at often from the edge of the
topography completely removes the view
of field seven and the additional
screening therefore the only panels that
can be seen are 1.2 kilometers away from
the village often
we feel that that is certainly an
appropriate change to the development
the other additions that we've made
we've added another 10 meter screening
buffer to the southeast of the
development to assist reviews from uh
from some neighboring properties in
harbury again listening we've also
removed some panels from an area of the
size in the center alongside one of the
prows to make sure that we are providing
the best immunity that we can through
the site
the revised layout also increases the
BMV sorry the um the uh the biodiversity
units from the site which go up from
33.99 to 98.6 for Habitat unit and from
2.9 to 10.55 for Hedgerow units and over
threefold inquiries in the biodiversity
of the site that's 30 seconds
it will launched by at 89 hectares of
land which is 0.05 of the County's land
it's reversible and only there for 40
years it's 94.5 to the side is non-bmv
land it will continue to be farmed 14.5
000 homes is the amount of homes that
will power or 12 uh just over 12 000
homes using the numbers from Stratford
it is a climate emergency and this has
been declared by Stratford District
councils also cost of living crisis with
fossil fuels being affected by price
increases due to the war in Ukraine
projects like Middle Road solar farm are
needed in order to attempt to stop and
reverse the uh the damage of climate
change
thank you very much thank you
okay members um
do you have any questions for Mr Wilder
or for Mr McKinney or Miss Gaffney
yes councilor Parry
thank you chair and good evening
um on the restructuring of this new
proposed application
um can you explain why you've kept the
field that's nearest to the Village of
often still in your plans because that
was one of the significant objections
that was made because of the
urbanization towards the village of
Afton
thank you very much it's a really good
question so when we looked at the the
layout of the soda scheme and we went
and we visited the pub which is that
Viewpoint that you can see there
it became very obvious that it's those
two Fields Fields five and six that
could be seen from the pub field seven
due to the Topography is largely as
you'll see in that image there invisible
and with the additional planting and the
strategy of how we're going to plant the
trees the management structure that's
been put in place for trimming uh the
Silver Birch which we planted near one
but removed I think a near 15 to
encourage a quick up growth of trees
you just can't see field seven from from
the pub and so what it allows us to do
is leave in what is a valuable part of
the development and enable us to
generate the most energy from the site
thank you yes Council Barry if I can of
course supplementary
um
I understand what you you just said
because you're talking about the view
from the white heart but what about
um urbanizing the Gateway entrance into
the village of Often by
keeping
field seven which was a key part of the
previous application
I'm sorry I'm not if what do you mean by
the Gateway sorry to ask a village
Gateway is its entrance and where it's
adjacent so where you have
um an area that's adjacent to often
forgive me I call that like a Gateway
entrance into the village
well obviously what we've done as part
of the assessment and the creation of
the application is to assess all of the
viewpoints that were agreed with the
district council and the planning
officers who reviewed the case
I don't believe that there is
from my visiting the site a large view
of the of field seven as you enter up
the roads because of the way that the
hedges are currently planted and the way
that you follow
I can't speak to whether that field is
visible from the road
um
but I certainly wouldn't say that is one
of the principal views of the Gateway of
the village
okay thank you the councilor Harvey
thank you chairman
as I understand solar farms and I don't
understand the technicalities but a
connection to the grid is a critical
factor is it not is there anything you
can say about this application and its
ease or otherwise of connective
connectivity with a grid
of course now I think all of us says and
I will have read in the news recently
that grid connections are very difficult
to come across especially for larger
ones with delays going out well into the
2030s that would be completely in
contradiction with the need to deliver
these sorts of developments to tackle
global climate change and reach out
blind our binding targets for netzera in
the UK
the project here connects to the
existing 132 KV overhead line that
travels through the site
it requires the addition of a new
substation which will be owned in
partnership with National Grid so they
were Western power till recently which
um all of you will know but they've
become National Grid energy distribution
so we will be constructing a single
Tower where they will be constructing a
single tee off Tower we'll be
constructing a new substation the
project requires no off-site upgrades so
as soon as we get consent for the
project we will start discharging the
conditions ordering the long lead items
and we'll be able to deliver this
project
within 12 months
but that is why it's important there are
no off-site upgrades that delay this
project but there would be for others
thank you for that
um looking around the room if there are
any further questions I have a question
myself I wonder if you'd help me
um
originally I think you proposed just
under 50 megawatts and this scheme is
still 50 megawatts yet you've
significantly reduced the number of
panels presumably can you explain how
you've managed to achieve that I mean
the panel's bigger higher more
noticeable what's changed in that
respect
well the first easy answer is time this
application was prepared in 2021 just
like all Electronics time causes the
things you're using to improve we've
been able to generate the additional
power required from less panels by the
fact that we are now
14 15 months later we'll be buying the
panels in another six months it's two
years that's a long amount of time we've
also managed to relocate a lot of the
panels that we removed from these areas
within other areas of the site just by
being more efficient with design and
also using a different type of mounting
structure which wasn't available as to
us previously that's where we are able
to use half tables so the mounting
structure because this is a moving
mounting structure is a new technology
there aren't very many manufacturers of
it originally my understanding is that
we were restricted to a certain length
of row that has changed and we can now
have half rows so that's the other
reason if you look at the scheme you'll
notice just small changes throughout
thank you for that any further questions
no I don't see any well thank you very
much indeed for your presentation
thank you all very much for your time
okay so um we have the ward member
speaking Council Ostrander so if
counselor off stranded you'd like to
approach the table
and uh
I have for you
um let's see five minutes to speak thank
you
thank you chair and committee
John Taylor of Upton Parish Council has
made a strong case regarding the
character of the landscape and the
importance of the topography on the site
however these are not the only points
relevant to this site but before I speak
further on that I would like to point
out that both Upton Parish Council and I
do understand the UK's need to reduce
our Reliance on fossil fuels and to meet
our obligations to reduce carbon
emissions I am entirely supportive of
Stratford District council's declared
climate emergency and I am generally in
favor of solar power
nonetheless there is a fine planning
balance in this case to be considered on
the one hand our need to reduce CO2
emissions and on the other hand the
points raised about the landscape
cumulative urbanization and visual
impact
there is additionally a further issue to
consider in this equation relating to
the use of agricultural land for solar
farms and the balance between fuel
security and food security
the land under under discussion was
classified as grade 3 in the
agricultural land classification
this classification is significant as
grade 3A land is considered the best and
most versatile land and according to
core strategy policy as-10 development
should prioritize Brownfield sites and
avoid best and most versatile land
furthermore the national policy
statement en3 for renewable energy has a
section on solar PV which includes
guidance on land type stating that where
possible ground mounted solar PV
projects should utilize agricultural
land preferably of classification 3b4
and 5.
the applicants commissioned a study to
determine if this land was 3A or 3B and
concluded that it was mainly 3B
the driver of this classification was
the degree of wetness with no other
Factor being significant and the margin
on the degree of wetness between the
land graded as 3A versus 3B across this
site was small
this suggests a very fine distinction in
grading this land is 3B and I believe
that there are two compelling arguments
suggesting that in fact this land is 3A
and thus best and most versatile
firstly Upton Parish Council consulted
with Michael Alder Emeritus professor
and the rural environment at Essex
University and fellow of the royal
Agricultural Society
he said that the data used for the
applicant's classification was based on
1989 meteorological data and that
up-to-date data would reflect the impact
of climate change
in his professional opinion he has said
that if you had 2023 meteorological
readings the agricultural land
classification of this site would be 3A
secondly crop yields from Land
immediately adjacent to the proposed
site are identified by Professor Alder
as being above National averages some by
a significant margin
data on which we have available
furthermore high quality baby Leaf salad
is produced on land also adjacent to the
site Natural England have said that
salad crops are typically grown on land
classified as grade one
these two points suggested in fact this
land is 3A and thus unsuitable for solar
PV the significance of this is enhanced
when considered in the context of food
security
recommendation nine of the national food
strategy suggests combining agricultural
land gradings with yield data to
determine what land to protect for food
production
I believe the case for both the land
classification as 3A and the above
average crop yields suggest that this
land should be protected for arable food
production
before I close I would like to offer the
committee some context on the level of
local support in opposing this project
and the original submission there were
32 objections
for this second application there have
been at least 180 objections including
from three parish councils and rmp in
contrast there have been only eight
expressions of support
the Secretary of State for leveling up
said in 2022 that the planning
inspectorate should not override
sensible local decision making which is
sensitive to and reflects local
constraints and concerns
thus localism should play an important
factor in the decision making today
in conclusion I believe that this solar
farm is not proposed for the right
location and as the previous Ward member
of often stated if it is not right it's
wrong
I thank you all for your time and
careful consideration of this matter
thank you counselor
um that was five minutes and six that's
very good I didn't even need to give you
a reminder of the 30 seconds uh members
do we have any questions for councilor
Ostrander please
oh sorry I was sort of looking um thank
you chair
um I just would just clarify uh Emeritus
Professor has actually conducted
a study of this particular piece of land
and produced a report
can I ask for clarification Parish
Council
is my light went off
has a report been produced and if a
report has been produced has it been
provided to the case officers
right
okay
um there is before you answer a point of
order chair it is not usually the
process that speakers to this committee
can take
um notes in their ear they either give
their answers or they don't and I have
in 20 years never seen a chair allowed
for somebody to be provided with
information in such a way
um I want a straight answer to what the
the speaker is saying I don't want
secondhand information the speaker has
the opportunity and we're just raising a
point of order here and I'm going to ask
you you know uh thank you thank you
counselor Pemberton well I'll ask the
legal officer if they feel that is if
that is relevant but I was told at the
beginning that because councilor
Ostrander was relatively new in her role
that
um the Clark was available to help
answer questions for technical nature
and this is um a complicated application
personally I don't see it's unreasonable
in this particular case but let me ask
legal advisor
I think it's within your discretion to
allow the speaker to check with other
members of of the chamber who might have
that information but that might affect
the weight that you choose to give the
answer that you get
okay thank you very much okay so I'm
quite happy for you to ask for technical
advice if you need it counselor
ostrender thank you I would just like to
say that I did request
um the clerk of the parish council to be
present for this purpose long before
this planning committee I did not want
to have this problem that has arisen I
did ask for her to be available and I
was reassured that that would be okay so
I am sorry if I have
I think I would just say that the
committee ought to be made you aware if
that's what's going to happen because
it's the first time I've seen it happen
chair I take absolutely what you say
you've made that representation I would
just observe that for the future if
that's going to happen the committee
should be made aware that there are
other people there to support and I if I
may have missed it but I didn't hear
that that was what was going to be
happening
well that's not counselor pembles and
that's noted for future meetings thank
you very much so the question is what is
the question about the existence and
status of a report
thank you
um Professor Alder has studied the
report that the applicants produced and
has commented via email the the uh the
comments that I've relayed to you
thank you counselor
thank you councilor Pemberton any
further questions for councilor
Ostrander please yes councilor hitch
there's one point on reference to
councilor Pemberton I in the past have
been sat in that chair there and I've
been allowed to turn around and ask
questions of certain people
okay thank you thank you for that any
further questions
then thank you very much councilor
Ostrander
thank you everyone
right now I'd like to move to uh any
points of clarification with officers on
this application please counselor Parry
first please and then councilor Harvey
thank you councilor Perry thank you
chair
um I note in the committee report there
were 10 letters of support from local
residents and third parties received can
the officer confirm who the third part
is were please
I.E
green energy groups or whatever it would
be really helpful
and I'd like to know how many third
parties as well thanks Joe
page 51
my viewers as as Joe's alluded to
when we're consolidating all of our
comments we we won't necessarily
check that you know every comment has
been received from a local resident and
anyone is able to comment on the
application
given the the number of representations
that we've received both in the form of
objections and also the fact that we've
received support we would have to go
through each and every one and determine
are they a local resident or are they
further afield what is their affiliation
to be defined as a third party so I
don't think we'd be able to answer that
properly for you
I think my point was really whether
there are organizations or individuals
concerned
thank you
councilor Harvey
thank you chairman we've got two
questions one is straightforward and
once perhaps more and more important the
straightforward ones page 67 the report
the officers report refers to
um I do consider the bespoke condition
bespoke condition is required specifying
the vegetation will will be maintained
throughout the lifetime of the
permission my question is whose
responsibility
is that for the maintenance is it the
operator or is it the landowner or is it
somebody else that's question one
it will be for the landowner at the time
and then they could do it very of
themselves between the operator but it
will be the responsibility of the land
thank you my second question is
if this application had been put forward
on the basis that it was to be located
on grade 3 a land
would that have changed your
recommendation
in all honesty I can't answer that
question because the assessment's been
done as in before you and that's what
the application is before you if it was
the gray 3A land
I I don't know it would be a different
assessment given the large scale or size
of the site you're talking eight nine
hectares of possible grade 3 on that
isn't the reports we've had what I
should also I like we've consulted with
natural England as you can see in the
assessment they said about how it
wouldn't
lead to Long significant effects so
natural ingrown response to express the
approach development is unlikely to lead
significant long-term loss of the best
and most versatile agricultural land and
that's how this application has been
assessed
thank you thank you a further question
councilor Fleming
going back
you talked about on an earlier
application tonight talking about joined
up thinking one of the speakers tonight
she talked about there are several other
solar farms in this area where this one
is proposed
how many acres have been lost to
agriculture because of solar farms in
that locality just so we got an idea I
mean at 90 at 90 hectares we're talking
of 200 acres of land for old guys like
me so you know I'd just like to have an
idea in my mind how much land we've lost
I think it's two two questions points to
that question firstly this is temporary
permission the land can be reinstated so
when you're saying loss of agricultural
land is temporary 40.6 years including
pretty much all of the solar Farms so it
can be reinstated I have to highlight
that that is even government guidance
secondly we do an assessment
commutatively in requirements and the
national planning framework on the
landscape impacts of it so I would be
lying to you if we sat here and gone as
you look it's set in a report saying how
far away the reports are but I'll be
lying if I'll be able to tell you
exactly how much acres all hectares are
in loss Community that's not part of our
assessment or criteria
I don't have the policy to do that and
all that's good yeah it's just that
we're turning part of Warwickshire into
a wasteland with these things and I just
like you know it was just an idea if we
could know what where we were with
councilor Edmond
hopefully Joe my question will be a bit
easier
um
for my own peace of mind could you
please show me the view from the pub and
point it at field seven
it's as simple as that thank you I'll
start with the field seven plan so you
can see it easier so that's field seven
right there from I've done that's the
road leading in and I'll show you there
you go
oh
sorry I was doing it too quick I do
apologize so anyway that's the red line
boundary there is field seven they're
the areas been removed that's the white
heart Pub that you can see that's been
annotated on there so if you come down
to the actual viewpoint
that Viewpoint this is the area there of
field seven so the way of doing it to be
honest and we did the side visits they
were characters is the S bend on the
road the S Pen pretty much donates that
field seven area of where the solar
panels would be just behind that field
there would be no solar panels
I think councilor hencher seraphin did
you indicate you had a question
okay
um
I had a point of clarification myself
Could you um Talk us through a little
bit about the to pop
um
yeah that's the S Bend that's what I'm
referring to
that's what it's in that vicinity so I'm
not
look look seriously I'm not lying if you
look at the red line boundary
I'm sorry we can't have a discussion
between the the chamber and the public
floor I'm very sorry not at this point
but I did have a question myself
um along similar lines actually because
uh the site visit today what we could
see was the Topography of the land
um falling away from the escarpment and
the first of the fields that was to have
solar panels I believe to be falling
away again is that is that correct we've
got anything that shows the sort of
topography of the first field the first
field that's the closest field to the
escarpment which will have solar panels
on it the applicant is correct as you
can see that's what I mean the the S
Bend is there where it's showing field
seven so that's the S Pen that we're
talking about so when you go back to the
application side
there's the s-band it's literally round
with another sensor they are correct and
that's what it's doing is trying to Mark
the two together it's not easy to do but
you see you have to use that road as a
viewpoint
so that point there and that's the
boundary of it
so just to to clarify he's trying to
clarify he is that you the best way to
do it in all honesty is that s Bend and
you can see that leads there that's the
whole point where you said so it's
Northern parcel northern eastern
Bayfield it is literally there in our so
it's a bit further on so you see from
the topography there it would be limited
in that area I think just
just to clarify one of the issues that
makes it more difficult to see which
fields are involved is that the area
that's shown on the plan doesn't exactly
match up with the current field
boundaries and hedges
there is I mean thus
that's how it's submitted there's no
denying that that area is more open than
the other fields and that's what you
have to do the sort of point of
reference for the S Bend and that's the
whole reason I put in that landscape bit
with Arrow coming down so there's no
denying up but field seven as denoted on
that plan which we're talking about five
and six have been removed so we go back
to this area that is field five and six
to remove field seven is on in that
vicinity of coming up so it's there but
it's right it's not this area that's why
I keep trying not to go into that area
it's within that vicinity just there
correct and the the point is that the
the land is is falling away there isn't
it the the Contours show a drop of about
15 meters across that field
I'd have to go back to look at the the
Contour plan that been submitted so I
don't want to okay
right I think it's fair to say that even
at the site visit it was quite difficult
to identify exactly which fields we were
looking at because of the Topography of
the closest field
any further questions from Members no
okay thank you very much
case we can move on to the the debate
about this application so who would like
to
offer to start
thank you councilor Perry
why is everybody turning to me looking
towards me
um
it's a bit Deja Vu here isn't it
I don't have a problem with the solar
farm on the harbor side with the fossway
I think that's perfectly appropriate
but I do have a problem
with
we have a solar farm then we have gaps
of fields and then we have
a wrap around solar farm a butting often
Village
not we've had a number of solar Farms
that have come before this planning
committee
and then normally
I'm not saying it's right but normally
they are
it's an area designated and it's all
joined up we don't have a little bit
here
then a bit of Greenfield and then we
have another extended side
I seriously believe
you know I'm very much in favor of solar
I have solar panels on my roof at home
and have done for the last
15 years
but I do feel that this application it's
come back again we refuse it in my view
for all the right reasons last time and
in my view there is an advert that the
changes haven't been significant one of
the things we said last time was that we
wanted to remove the area of solar solar
displays around the Afton area
they've paid lip service to that by
removing solar PV panels in two of the
fields but it's still a Bots the village
of often as we have heard from the Ward
member
confirmation from a a professional
expert saying it's grade three
agricultural land I still feel the
fields that have put around the village
of urban still cause an urbanization
impact to the Village of often I still
feel there's an adverse impact on the
character of the landscape
and I also we've got the grade three and
in addition this whole part of the
district is becoming Solar City
and therefore I wish to propose refusal
of this application thank you chair okay
thank you counselor Perry
um in respect of the fields that are
involved here and you've used the words
the solar farm abuts The Village often
um the planning officers offered to try
and help
clarify that because it's not being
clear thus far in this presentation so
he's just working on that now I don't
know if you need a a break it suggested
we might take a break but I think the
case officer might have got a little bit
further with it
so this is the photo the part another
photo as part of the Audi IA and also
was submitted without the photo montage
by yapkin this is field seven here and
that is ziti zooming in to show field
sevens this is five and six behind
that's the S Pen that I was trying to
refer to because I said it's not easy
and that's field seven standing across
where the solar panels are proposed as
you can see there this is five and six
that is field seven Joe could I ask
where that view is taken from is it from
the pub Garden yeah so this is what I
mean of we have to really zoom in to try
and show that area could you just do
that again then because I think what
you're highlighting is that from the pub
the um
the fall on that field seven is it's
falling away towards the flat fields
that have now been excluded from this
proposal it's falling away
so that your
um
your view of that whilst you will see
some of it is mitigated by the the
actual the Topography of that field
would that be correct fundamentally like
it's not easy to see and that's what how
far is that field from the village of
Upton
taught my head I can't give you that
answer the easiest way to show that is
go back to
hopefully that that helps just clarify
exactly which field seven is
counselor chair the problem I was not I
was not raising a problem from the white
heart as a view I was raising the
problem of the proximity of the solar
arrays to often Village that is my issue
not from the view from the white heart
and I have visited the site not on this
recent occasion but in the past
okay well I was just simply seeking to
make it absolutely clear which field we
were talking about where it was whether
it abutted the village of Upton it's
something
probably 800 meters away or something
like that and the Topography is such
that it falls away I just wanted to
clarify that
um questions from councilor Pemberton I
think you had your hand up
counselor Hench seraphin first thank you
chair
um
I totally agree with councilor Perry
and also
the amount of agricultural and good
Agricultural and swallowing up
is to my mind when we need to actually
grow more food
is not the right place I'm in favor of
solar panels you know over car Parks
over industrial buildings that don't
take up any space but these are just
taking up agricultural land all the time
so I'm against this application thank
you councilor Pemberton
thank you not for once in my life I find
myself taking a contrary position
um first of all I would caution this
committee to hang its hat on
professor emeritus
we are not in possession of a report
that is there is no evidence presented
to this Committee of a piece of work
done
that will be able to pass muster for our
decision making
um
it's not nothing has been presented to
officers
um it's a bad an email exchange and I
would really caution members to want to
hang their hat on classifying this land
in such a way which is why I
specifically asked the question because
it could have been a determining Factor
but there is no evidence in front of us
or in front of officers
it's not much more than hearsay in real
term so I would caution members at that
point
um
I know
councilor hencher serafin's desire and
uh for us not to build solar Farms but
we have to deal with what's in front of
us I would observe that solar Farms have
to have a certain mass and scale to
actually work and there are significant
logistical issues around the question of
solar arrays on tops of buildings this
Authority itself
investigated a solar array on its on one
of its major car parks and couldn't make
it work it's a really nice to have but
the tech doesn't appear to be there you
have a solar farm where the key issue
appears to be field seven and
it is difficult to see from a visual
perspective how field seven has an
adverse impact on the landscape
um
and there is the question of
loss of agricultural land there's no
evidence that it is the most best and
versatile land
it is the temporary withdrawal of
agricultural land and 100 odd years ago
we used to take Fields out of commission
on a regular basis they called it crop
rotation
and I might argue that some of our food
production is not necessarily improved
by not crop rotation that said that's a
digression away from planning a policy
there but
um the notion or the question of food
security we are talking about an
infinitesimal amount of agricultural
land in this country and would make no
difference whatsoever in terms of food
security and I I discount that as a
planning reason I do play significant
weight on the need to decarbonize our
energy Supply I accept that
by the nature of things this part of the
district is more suitable than others
and is therefore more in the far in line
and that presents a challenge but
somebody in this chamber did once say
that we'll drag people kicking and
screaming to change as far as the
climate is concerned and
I'm happy to say that we should we
should be proposing this one we do need
to increase the amount of solar and
non-fossil fuel energy and for me that
is the overriding consideration there is
no for me particular impact on the uh
visual impact uh here it is uh I I did
not sit on the previous committee and
saw the previous application but reading
the papers and looking at I do believe
there's been a sufficient amendment I am
prepared to back officers
recommendations on this one I suspect
however I am in a minority so can I take
that as a proposal well you have two
proposal Snapchat yeah I'll take that as
a proposal from you then councilor
Pemberton to support the officer's
recommendation thank you councilor
Harvey thank you Kevin
um
I think councilor Pemberton has raised a
pertinent matter
I the basis bond with Dish upon which
committee this committee takes decisions
there has been a recent case
where the committee refused and
the telling Factor was a contribution
from a counselor
uh that amounted to effectively hearsay
the term cancer Pemberton used the
matter went to appeal
the appeal was granted
and not only that but because the
decision had been made in part based
upon an assertion rather than evidence
there's the question of costs to be
awarded against the council that is yet
to be determined but costs have been
awarded the officers will know the case
um so I I that's the first question if
you're going to make a decision it's got
to be on on the basis of evidence that's
been tested you can't do it on SIMPLE
assertions however attractive and
however persuasive the assertions might
be the second thing I'd like to point to
is committee decisions on solar panel
Farms
um generally that from recollection I
think there have been something like 15.
I think the first one was lost or was
refused and on appeal it was confirmed
as refused but ever since then
officers have considered uh applications
for solar farms and having weighed them
the the arguments and the planning
balance have recommended approval
not all of those have been accepted by
the committee and some have been refused
but I do think I'm right in saying that
in every instance that a refusal has
gone to appeal the appeal has been
allowed in other words the officers got
it right first time round
my view on this one is that
we have declared a climate emergency
Europe
Mediterranean over the past three four
weeks has been burning
this is evidence that the pace of change
where climate change is concerned is to
forgive the phrase hotting up and we
need to accept that either we're serious
about this or we're not and in my view I
do accept that the there will be some
visual impact of this proposal I I don't
deny that but when I weigh the future of
my grandchildren
in the balance and what the world will
be like
oh do I want to see am I prepared to put
up with the view of
solar panels in fields as opposed to not
and having all the problems we will have
with with energy Supply then I know
where my my uh my vote will go so I'm
conscious the officers do tend to get it
right
the evidence that that has been
presented to us in this report supports
the recommendation we have declared a
climate emergency and I will support uh
I'll second councilor pemberton's uh
recommend or proposal to refuse
well thank you very much councilor
Harvey
um would anybody else like to speak I've
certainly got something to say anybody
else like sweet councilor Fleming
I can't get over the the rush to provide
solar farms at the total expensive uh
the agricultural land
um
I agree we need to do something and we
need to have solar forums and whatever
else but do we need him concentrated in
one area Warwickshire you know we're
renowned for having a lovely Green
County won't be green for long it'd be
the color of a solar panel so from that
perspective
um
I would probably go against the
officer's recommendation and I'd support
councilor Perry at this particular point
in councilor Harris
so that's my view
thank you councilor Fleming um
the planning managers just asked if she
can make a clarification in respect of
this issue of loss of agricultural land
and I'm going to ask her to to make a
comment there because it might influence
this debate thank you Emily
thank you chair
um as as members of the committee are
aware this this application has been
resubmitted following
um a previous decision made by this
committee to refuse that application I
just want to draw
um reference to the reason for refusal
there which there was one reason for
refusal and please mind me I'm going to
read it to you exactly as it was written
and this was written based on the
discussions of that night
the proposed development by reason of
its scale and size would represent a
visually intrusive development in the
open Countryside which would not be
sensitive and would seriously detract
from the open and Rural character and
appearance of the landscape the proposal
has a significant adverse in urbanizing
effect on the landscape character
especially in consideration of the
cumulative impact on the open landscape
and as such it is not considered that
the development could be made acceptable
or that the benefits outweigh the harm
consequently The Proposal is considered
contrary to policies CS5 and cs9 of the
Stratford of penhaven core strategy
the reason I've read that out to you is
that that does not refer to loss of
agricultural land
and I would urge you to consider whether
you feel that the circumstances have
changed particularly as councilor
Pemberton has referred we have not seen
the um the evidence that was referred to
by by the councilor in respect of the um
the professor who has
allegedly
scrutinized the agricultural land
classification report that was submitted
to us so as far as the recommendation
that we have made and the information
that we have given to you as a committee
and you've been able to refer to we do
not believe that we have been able to
consider that as part of the assessment
so as I say I just want to be mindful
that when the decision was previously
made that reason for refusal did not
consider the loss of agricultural land
thank you chair
okay thank you for that clarification
um anybody else like to enter the debate
counts for Parry
um just really a question back to
um the planning manager
um obviously since since the last
um refusal was made
um there has been a greater emphasis on
the cost of living crisis and the cost
of food so there has been a a step
change in terms of government focus on
producing more food from the UK and that
has arisen as a result of the cost of
living crisis where we've had inflation
up 10 percent
um that is coming down but as a whole
there has been an increased issue on the
cost of living for food production since
this last came to committee
okay thank you councilor Perry anybody
else like to enter the debate or shall I
make my views known at this point okay
so um having me to the site today I can
see that there is some impact of solar
panels on that field although I think
that they're
um probably less than uh less than
significant
the loss of agricultural land is
temporary it's a temporary permission
this development could be reinstated
almost at any time if it was absolutely
essential
I don't think I can place any particular
weight on a hearsay agricultural report
that challenges that the grading of the
land is incorrect
and I can see that it's um an imperative
for us having to collect a climate
emergency to support uh solar
solar farms and renewal of renewable
energy and in fact that's made very
clear in the officers report so the way
I'm feeling about this is that I am in
agreement with the officer's
recommendation because I think that the
the benefits of um of this 50 megawatt
from
outweighing the the harm to the
landscape which incidentally hasn't got
any special protection or designation in
it as I read it so that's that's my
position so could I ask other counselors
if you like to enter the debate
okay well if not then I would like to
just clarify I believe that I had a
proposal from councilor Parry
um early on in the debate would that be
correct councilor Perry to um
not to go again to go against the
officer's recommendation and to refuse
this could you help me understand what
material planning reason you would give
for that refusal
I still feel there is an adverse impact
on the rural character
of the landscape and the village of
Afton
by virtue of the scale and size of
the
um solar panel of the fields that are
used with it that surround
um often
as I said in my previous thing I didn't
have a problem with the the fields
adjacent to the Foss way
um and I do I do feel in like of the
cost of living crisis we have a food
security problem that we do need to
protect
um
and as far as I'm concerned that stands
okay thank you for that councilor Perry
now councilor Hendra seraphin I think at
one point you were minded to Second The
Proposal of councilor Parry is that
correct I will second cancel the parish
proposal thank you for that
on a second
so we've got legal Point here that
because
councilor hencher seraphin
didn't second the motion of counselor
Parry
at the time
and counselor Pemberton made a proposal
to support the officer's recommendation
councilor pemberton's proposal is the
first proposal but I do take
your seconding of counselor parries
motion
right so can I clarify with councilor
Pemberton that he's still happy to
propose a support the recommendation by
the officers I am
thank you councilor Pemberton and
councilor Harvey you're confirming that
you're prepared to second that confirmed
thank you
okay so we're at the point now where I'm
going to move us to a vote on this and
that is to vote on
um councilor pemberton's proposal to
accept the recommendation of the case
officers
to um Grant planning permission for
application
2301305 for land near to Middle Road
Farm Middle Road harbory so could I
please see those in favor of that
proposal
three
thank you very much and could I see
those against that proposal please
three
so an abstention
thank you
apparently that puts me in casting vote
territory I'm told
um I have just supported
councilor pemberton's proposal to go
with the office's recommendation to
Grant this permission and I use my
casting vote to Grant it thank you very
much
so that is a resolution of this
committee to Grant the application
2301 305 ful land near to Middle Road
Farm Middle Road harboring thank you all
very much
I think we just take a five minute
recess if that's okay for a drink of
water and such like and counselor Adam
is going to come back into the chair
thank you
okay members thank you very much
councilor Keithley for uh chairing that
item we now have to we've just hit 8 30
which means we have to decide whether
we're prepared to go on and
no
three hours fine in which case we move
on to item item seven
now
we do have a registered speaker but
um it appears that uh they're not
present at the meeting in which case the
reason for it to be referred to
committee is no longer present I propose
that we delegate to officers do we have
any
country opinions to that
it's a general support from the members
in which case that can be delegated to
officers
which case we now move to item nine
urgent business
no urgent business in which case I can
close the meeting thank you very much